TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
DID PRESIDENT BIDEN HAVE A
SECRET DEAL WITH THE SAUDI
CROWN PRINCE?
WHO BROKE THAT DEAL?
MEDIA REPORTS SUGGEST THAT
SOMETHING WAS AGREED, TO
SAUDIS WOULD INCREASE
PRODUCTION OF
OIL.
BUT SAUDI ARABIA DID HAVE A
DEAL, JUST NOT WITH US.
WITH RUSSIA.
IMAGINE HOW ENERGY LANDING
SCAPE WOULD BE DIFFERENT IF
THE U.S. STAYED ON THE PATH
OF ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
JOINING US DR. JOHN
BARRASSO.
LOT ME ASK YOU WHETHER OR
NOT YOU BELIEVE THAT
REPORTING IS ACCURATE OR
THERE WAS A DEAL TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION?
AND IF SO, WHAT COULD HAVE
HAPPENED?
>> TREY THANK YOU.
JOE BIDEN HAS PUT AMERICA IN
A POSITION WE HAVE A KICK-ME
SIGN ON OUR BACK.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THAT
SAUDI ARABIA WOULD TREAT US
THE WAY THEY HAVE WITH
REGARD TO ENERGY.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
TODAY IN AMERICA, THINGS
THAT HAPPENED IN LAST TWO
YEARS WITH JOE BIDEN TO
WEAKEN OUR NATION, WHETHER
40% HIGH INFLATION, OR CRIME
OR IN THE CITIES AND POROUS
BORDER THEY HAVE ALL
WEAKENED IN NOW TO SPECIFICS
OF ENERGY, I AM IN WYOMING.
I THINK THAT GREATEST SIN OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THAT OF
GIVING UP AMERICA'S ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE HAD IT, WE DON'T HAVE IT
NOW, I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT
SAUDI ARABIA WOULD TREAT US
THE WAY THEY HAVE.
THERE IS A SOLUTION TO THIS.
THAT SOLUTION IS MORE
AMERICAN ENERGY.
BUT JOE BIDEN AND EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT, WHO IS
RUNNING THIS YEAR AND SERVES
IN HOUSE AND SENATE THEY
HAVE A DIFFERENT IDEA, THEY
DO WHATEVER THE CLIMATE
EXTREMISTS TELL THEM TO DO,
WHAT THEY DEMAND OF THE FAR
LEFT GROUP, AND THEY SHUT
OFF, CHOKE OFF
ENERGY PRODUCTION THEY HAVE
USED UP OUR EMERGENCY
SUPPLIES WE'RE IN AN ENERGY
WAR AND THE
PRESIDENT DOES NOT WANT TO
ADMIT IT.
TREY: I AM IN BELIEVER IN
SETTING REALISTIC
EXPECTATIONS, LET'S ASSUME
FOR SAKE OF ARGUMENT THAT
REPUBLICANS RETAKE SENATE,
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN
DO, PRESSURE YOU CAN PUT TO
GET JOE BIDEN TO GO BACK TO
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE DAYS.
>> A NUMBER OF THINGS I I
WOULD BE CHAIRMAN OF THE
ENERGY COMMITTEE IN U.S.
SENATE MY FOCUS WOULD BE ON
LOWERS COST OF ENERGY FOR
AMERICAN PUBLIC, THAT
INVOLVING UNLEASHING
AMERICAN ENERGY, WE NEED TO
RESTORE OR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND ECONOMY.
WHICH IS HUGE HERE.
WE'LL BE PUTTING FORWARD
LEGISLATION, AND IT WITH
OVERSIGHT AND WITH WHO GETS
CONFIRMED TO DIFFERENT
POSITIONS IN THE ECONOMY,
THESE THINGS FOCUSED ON MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE, PIPELINES,
MORE OIL AND GAS PERMITS,
AND NO DEPENDENCE ON ANYONE
WHETHER CRITICAL MINERALS
FROM CHINA OR OIL FROM
RUSSIA OR SAUDI ARABIA.
WE -- AND LOOK, YOU KNOW
THIS, WE NEED ALL OF THE
ENERGY, WE NEED THE OIL, THE
GAS, WE NEED THE SOLAR AND
WIND, WE NEED IT ALL, FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL SANTA ANA
SANTA ANA POINT WE NEED
-- STAND POINT
TO CONTINUE TO MAKE ENERGY
CLEAN AS WE CAN.
PEOPLE ARE SO BAD, I AM
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR
REPUBLICAN CHANCES OF TAKING
THE HOUSE AND TAKING THE
SENATE.
COME NEXT TUESDAY.
TREY: BEFORE I LET YOU GO,
SENATOR, THIS IS WHAT VEXES
ME, EVEN IF THE CLIMATE OR
ENVIRONMENT IS YOUR NUMBER
ONE ISSUE, HOW IS SAUDI
ARABIA OIL CLEANER THAN
AMERICAN OIL?
IF YOU ASK THE SAUDIS TO
INCREASE PRODUCTION, THAT
MEANS WE NEED MORE ENERGY,
WHY NOT USE AMERICAN ENERGY.
>>
>> WE'RE THE BEST
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDS, I
WAS GETTING MY OIL CHANGES
YESTERDAY, TALKING TO FOLKS,
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW IN
TERMS OF ENERGY IN WYOMING
ECONOMY IT IS PERSONAL AND
EMOTIONAL WE UNDERSTAND
WE'RE TIED UP IN RED TAPE
FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION
AFFORDABLE ENERGY IS THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THIS NATION.
FOR FOLKS, IF YOU WANT TO
STOP THE DAMAGE THIS BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT HAS DONE TO
THIS COUNTRY OVER LAST TWO
YEARS, WE NEED TO VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS, HOUSE AND
SENATE ON TUESDAY.
TREY: SENATOR DR. JOHN
BARRASSO, MAY BE IN CHARGE
IN SENATE OF ENE